Center It's A genus of single-celled  eukaryote there are 19 known species but  they're probably more than that some of  them can build mucous houses that they  can hang out in and hide inside of some  carry algae inside of them that produce  food for them and all of them are  astoundingly large for a single-celled  organism some can be as much as four  millimeters long big enough to be seen  without a microscope the biggest of all  the stentors and one of the largest  single-celled organisms that exists is  stenter corralius they can be the length  of a rice grain there are insects in  your backyard that are smaller than  these massive but common unicellular  organisms they're in freshwater habitats  all around the world and we here at  Journey to the microcosmos have a pond  where we find them all the time